number two there's an immense amount of
fear
driving all of this I said that so many
of the people I encounter on the street
appear to be confused
and some of them actually are confused
one woman in in particular was was so
committed to the relativistic view that
we all have our own truths
that when I asked her um you know what
would happen if it was my truth
that she no longer exists
she looked me dead in the eyes and said
well then then I don't exist
if it's your truth that I don't exist
then I don't
now I knew that women were being erased
in our culture I didn't realize that
some of them were so eager to erase
themselves
but more often I encounter people who
whose confusion seems to be more of an
affectation
you know they give vague dodgy answers
to the questions because they're afraid
to speak basic biological truths
especially afraid to do it on camera
there are many people I always stopped
on the street who refused to talk to us
at all telling us that uh they cannot
talk about this with cameras rolling
because they'll lose their job their
friends and everything in their lives
so to be clear their lives will be
destroyed
if they said something like only women
have babies on camera
or any similarly provocative statement
so gender ideology paves the way
for itself with intimidation threats
coercion
fear is a big part of the story
the third thing I learned is that none
of this is new at least not as new as it
seems anyway
so the roots of modern gender ideology
could be traced all the way back to the
19th century arguably even earlier than
that as the author Carl Truman explained
in our film and also in his great book
which I highly recommend called The Rise
and Triumph of the modern self if you've
never seen that or read that book he
talks about how the stage was set with
the birth of of what philosophers some
philosophers have dubbed psychological
man and that is when human beings began
to prioritize their own emotional
well-being Above All Else and to see
emotional contentment as life's primary
aim and purpose
so man moved away from defining himself
based on and seeking joy in
um his roles and responsibilities within
larger social structures the family the
church the nation even the workplace
moved away from that and increasingly
his life revolved around his
self-perception
and whatever he did was in service to
that self-perception
and now we've gotten to a point
where for an individual it's not only
that that their self-perception is the
only thing that they care about
but they expect that it's going to be
the only thing you care about
that their self-perception is your
project it's your chore it's something
that you have to take responsibility for
and that's the the stage upon which the
gender ideology drama has played out and
that really began to take its current
shape in the mid 20th century thanks to
the work of two hideously evil crackpot
degenerates named Alfred Kinsey and John
money who together along with a few
other shaped gender ideology as we know
it as we know it today excuse me
number four
I learned that the ultimate goal of the
gender ideology agenda goes far beyond
gender you know the ultimate goal is to
undermine destroy and erase truth itself
leftism is relativism and relativism is
the belief that there is no objective
truth there is no shared reality there's
no Universal fact that we all have to
conform around and submit ourselves to
the relativist claims the right to
invent his own Universe for himself even
to the point of inventing himself he
seeks to be a self-created being making
and remaking himself as he sees fit
right down to the biological level he
believes that his ego overrides
everything
must bow before it language institutions
science even his own DNA
must bow to his ego
this is why I found myself in the film
speaking to Pontius Pilate over and over
again you know what is truth he asks in
Scripture
and the same thing the gender audio log
asks well what is truth who's truth
which truth
I was sitting in the same room as them
but they would not agree that we were
situated in the same reality
so we can share a room but we can't
share a universe they tell us
because they get their own they insisted
and that ultimately is what this is all
about
but here's the good news number five
here's the other thing I learned
the final thing I learned from from
spending a year staring into this Abyss
is that we can win this fight you know
gender ideology is insane destructive
pervasive ubiquitous I believe the
greatest evil
that the world has ever seen
it's also beatable
it's weak and it's flimsy
you know I get asked all the time by
people
do you really want to die on this hill
is this the hill you want to die on they
always say to me
and and they say that about everything I
say and In fairness sometimes I do pick
some rather odd Hills to die on but
this particular issue I hear that a lot
well you know why is this why do you
want to die on this hill
will I die on this hill the answer is
yes
you know I will die on this hill
if there's any Hill worth dying on it's
the hill of of objective truth
because if we surrender
if we surrender
that's why I always ask conservatives
who are who are willing to surrender the
hill I say well what
what's your plan from here what's next
so you're going to give up the hill of
truth and reality and then what
where do you go from there
what Hills are left after you've given
that up
so yeah I'll die on this hill
but I don't plan on it
I don't want to
as General Patton said back in the days
before the military cared about equity
and tolerance he said no bastard ever
won a war by dying for his country he
wanted by making some other poor dumb
bastard die for his
and I kind of feel that way about the
hills that were all metaphorically
fighting them
um I would say the same for the hill you
know this this fight for for truth this
struggle against gender lunacy
we can win
because the other side can be crushed
under the weight of simple questions
I saw this happen time and time again
before my very eyes right the learned
the educated the the experts crumpled
and collapsed and panicked in front of
me me a a bumpkin in a flannel armed
with a high school diploma
now is that because I'm brilliant
that is my preferred adjective as you
know
it's how I self-identify
and handsome thank you
that's how I identify it's my truth
um
but no fortunately for me Brilliance is
not actually required
if it was then I couldn't
be in this fight
all we have to do is just stand up look
this thing directly in its face
and ask it questions
serve it a healthy dose of skepticism
force it to explain itself
it has to explain itself the burden of
proof is on it
gender ideology the person who comes
promoting gender ideology they have to
explain themselves
see they always want to flip it around
and they say well
what do you mean men can't have babies
well explain that
no no no no I don't need to explain that
okay I'm in alignment
with the entire history of the human
race
you came along 15 seconds ago and said
that no everybody who's ever lived is
wrong about this okay well you know what
you need to explain that the burden of
proof is one thousand percent on you so
you proved to me that a man can have
babies you prove that to me and if you
can't get the hell out of my face
now
sir
but they can't they can't prove that
[Applause]
not only can they not prove that a man
can have babies they can't even tell you
what a man is
they can't answer anything
they have perched themselves on a limb
that isn't even connected to a tree
they're anchored to nothing
their worldview is empty and frail and
flimsy
so we don't need to be armed with
anything but a spine
for all the talk accusing me and others
of advocating violence or being
terrorists
the only thing we're coming armed with
is yeah a spine in questions that's all
we have
you just have to have enough to stand up
straight and ask the questions that they
cannot answer the question is that for
that reason are not supposed to be asked
but we must ask them
and if we do we will win
and we must win too
that's it for me thank you everybody
[Applause]
[Music]